in this game dev tutorial you will learn
how to create a first person shooter
game using unreal engine and c plus fah
here teaches this course he has created
a ton of game development tutorials and
he is an excellent teacher
what is up guys fire here but you
already know that
do you
anyways welcome to another unreal engine
tutorial this time we have a first
person shooter c plus plus game yes c
plus plus yeah i i give me it uh i have
a lot of things to say but i know you
don't want to hear
so let's just take a look at the game
that we are going to create so this is
the layout of the game as you can see we
have this huge well huge level it is a
big level and we have all of these
enemies here that are waiting for us
where we need to pass by so that we can
get all the way through here and i'm
going to speed it up and then here and
then here till this door and this is the
end of the game we of course have a
timer and we also you know have the
enemies who are attacking us so if i
preview the game if i hit the play
button you will see the timer here i
also have my player held at the bottom
left and the enemies have their own
health i can shoot the enemies and you
can also hear all of them look at that
so there you go shoot
and one more time and the enemy is dead
and this is too loud so i think i think
i need to you know lower the volume just
a little bit there you go but anyways
this is you know basically the game so
we need to pass by here shoot these
enemies of course you will have
assignments in this you know
mini course where you will have to
create your own system for having you
know a limited number of weapons
actually bullets and so on and so forth
and the enemies when they get close to
me look at that so they are going to
deal damage you see and this is too much
damage as you can see too much damage
i'm going to kill this bad boy
i don't know what this [ __ ] thinking
was but anyways this is our game as you
can see and all of this is created in c
plus of course with combinations with
blueprints but five percent blueprints
because we simply cannot avoid
blueprints when you create something in
c plus plus you need to convert that
into a blueprint to use it right here in
the editor or in your game but the
important part is that we will learn a
lot of cool things such as ai perception
which is basically giving your enemies
the ability to have sight hearing and
stuff like that so yeah that would be it
as you can see the game looks simple but
we're going to learn a lot of cool and
complicated things such as the ai
perception and the site component of it
and how to use that in order to detect
the player and so on and so forth so a
lot of useful info is inside of this
mini course and yeah i don't have
anything else to say except you know
subscribe like and all of that stuff and
uh let's get into the game and create
this really cool game what up peoples we
are back again with unreal engine and
again this time we are going to as
always create a game with c plus plus an
unreal engine so this is a new project
as you can see i have the project
browser and over here we are going to
create a game because we're not a tv
producers and architectures and
automotive people so we're going to
click here next and we are going to
select the first person so not blank
project not the puzzle flying whatever
we want the first person and go here and
again when i say go here i mean next and
over here we have the blueprint so we're
going to change to c plus plus
everything else can stay the same with
starter contact because we need it i
need the starter content so badly and
over here i am going to name this one
monster
shooter there you go because we shoot
monsters okay vampires or whatever and
we are going to click here to create a
project now of course you know that you
know it's tedious with unreal engine all
that stuff it takes you know probably a
year or two for it to load and compile
unity is getting closer you know takes a
lot of time also to create and compile
and whatnot so i am probably going to
you know cut out the video right here
and i will see you back hopefully if
this you know finishes up until tomorrow
so yeah
let's wait and i will see you when this
you know the project loads finally
unreal engine showed mercy and decided
to create the project and here we are
now of course before we proceed because
we are going to first cover the player
and all of that stuff we are also going
to import our own mesh because over here
we have the meshes folder and this is
not what we want instead we want this
let me just go back here content and i'm
going to right click over here in new
folder and create the meshes folder over
here at the top you see content
and over here we're going to import our
own mesh which is basically the vampire
or the 3d model that we are going to use
now you will be able to download it link
will be down below this video so just
click on the link it will start
downloading and
also you will have a complete project so
this finished project that we are
currently doing you can also download it
this is for reference purposes that you
can download maybe copy and paste some
code that you don't want to type out or
compare your code to mine and so on and
so forth so i'm going to simply drag and
drop the vampire over here we do need to
make sure to import all and wait for the
vampire to import now hopefully this is
not going to take too long because in
the meantime i can sync to you or
whatnot don't worry about whatever
warning you got so don't worry about
that next i'm going to import his idle
animation over here import all and last
but not least i'm going to import the
vampire running animation there you go
let's go over here and import and there
you go so now
i am not going to do anything with the
monster with the vampire and whatnot we
are going to do that later on so don't
worry about that this is just for you
know saving purposes so the first step
that we are going to do is we are going
to create our game character so we are
going to go here inside of our c plus
plus classes and monster shooter and
over here we have the monster shooter
character and all of that stuff we don't
want all of this we simply want to click
here new c plus plus class that will
inherit from the character itself and
i'm going to click on next and i am
going to call this one monster so
monster shooter character this is the
name of our class and i'm going to hit
here click create class and i have
issues when i talk you know as you
probably noticed anyways it is not
important by the way i have a new blog
that is hopefully out i mean the day i'm
recording this video the blog is still
being made but the day this video will
be published
the blog will probably be up so you will
see a link down below if you like
written tutorials you don't want to
listen to my voice and whatnot maybe you
hate it or whatever so i'm just going to
double click this and open it here
reload all you can also follow along
maybe i will have this tutorial in a
written form as well i don't know just
you know comment down below if you like
written tutorials and if you like me to
create more written tutorials on my blog
so over here right below the player
setup player
input component i am going to create a
public
properties so the first one is going to
be property or u property and this is
going to be visible defaults
only and from here we're going to say
category is equal to mesh and also well
over here closing the parentheses and
i'm going to declare it as a class use
skeletal
mesh
component with a star because it's a
pointer and i'm going to call this one
hand mesh which is going to be our hands
that you know we're going to use to
shoot
now moving forward i'm also going to
copy this over here and we already know
what this visible defaults only is what
the category is the category will put it
under the category mesh when we try to
search it inside of the blueprint
visible defaults only will make the
properties visible of the skeletal
default or skeletal mesh component next
we are also going to have another
skeletal mesh components i'm simply
going to paste all of this here but this
time we're not going to call it hand
mesh but i'm going to call it guns
or gun mesh
because you know we have hands that you
know our hands and we also have guns
that those hands are holding so next we
are going to have your property but let
me just go over here and copy this so
that we don't have to every single time
time type it out so we have the visible
defaults only category mesh but this one
is going to be class u
scene
component there you go and this one is
going to be the muzzle location or
basically the the location from where we
are going to shoot
paste again the u property and this one
is not going to be visible defaults but
this one is going to be visible anywhere
so it's anywhere there we go
the category i'm going to say here is
equal to camera and i'm also going to
make it blueprint so blueprint read only
so we can also read it in the blueprint
and over here class you camera it's not
conduer it's camera component there you
go and i'm going to call this one first
person camera or fps camera however you
want to call it
now next we're going to have a few more
variables for the movement and over here
i'm going to say you property
and this one is going to be visible
anywhere and blueprint so blueprint
read only category is going to be equal
to camera so camera there you go close
the parentheses and this one is going to
be our float turn rate
i am also going to copy this right here
and paste it over here because it's also
going to be or this variable is going to
be a u property visible anywhere
blueprint rings only category camera and
instead of turn rate this is going to be
our look up rate there you go
and we're also going to have the gun
offset and this one is going to be you
property and i'm going to say edit
anywhere and over here it's going to be
blue
so blue print read right and the
category is going to be equal to
gameplay like that and this one is going
to be our f vector
gun offset there you go and we're going
to use this gun offset to offset the gun
and we're going to see that don't worry
next we are going to have protected
variables or basically protected
functions
the first one is going to be void on
fire this
tutorial is on fire
there you go i'm also singing so over
here we're also going to avoid move
forward there it goes for word like that
and takes a float value as a parameter
we're also going to have void
move right and takes a float
value as a parameter
void
turn at rate having a float rate
parameter and void look at rate having a
float rate parameter now you can of
course pause the video and copy all of
these because these are the default
functions that we every single time we
need to create because you know
it's simple we need we need those in
order for you know everything to work
i mean move forward move right look turn
at rate look at the rates over here for
the fire i'm going to right click on it
and quick actions and refactoring and
over here we're going to create a
declaration inside of the c plus plus
class because we know that in the dot h
file we only declare things and then we
need to implement them inside of the c
plus file so over here do the same thing
for all of these it will save us time
instead of us going out there in the
class and typing all of this out so
right click quick actions refactoring
and there you go so you can now go over
here and see that all of these are
created so move forward move right look
at rate turn at rate and all of that
stuff and over here we are first going
to have some includes and i'm simply
going to paste them so we have the
includes for the camera for the capsule
and for the input component
now what's important for you to you know
do is do these includes right away so
don't you know don't wait for
whatever just do the includes pause the
video and do that
i have a practice of doing these
includes you know right when we start
with the tutorial or when we start with
a certain part of the tutorial so that i
don't go back and forth every single
time we need a certain component in the
code and oh i need to include this as
well oh i forgot to include this you get
the point so do the includes right here
right now otherwise
i will kidnap you in teacher game
development okay so moving forward over
here inside of the constructor is where
we are going to construct everything so
the first step is to get the capsule
component and from it i am going to init
capsule size and set the size to 40
f and 95.0
f this is the default value of the
capsule and of course we can change that
in the editor but i like to do things
you know like this when we do c plus
plus goes i cause code i don't know
about you but i really like typing out
code so maybe somebody doesn't like it
so there you go so turn rate is going to
be equal to
45.0 f there you go look up rate is
going to be equal to also 45.0 f
now the first thing that we are going to
do is we are going to create the camera
component and
well in order to create a camera we
simply need to say first person camera
is equal to create default sub object
type of view camera component and text
over here which is going to be the name
so inside of text we're going to give
the camera the name first person camera
simple as that what do you expect am i
going to give it the name carl it's not
my child okay
first person camera and from here we're
going to say set up attachment and we're
going to attach it on the capsule
component so get capsule component there
you go this is where we are going to
attach the first person camera i'm also
going to add relative location so first
person camera and i'm going to say add
relative location
and the relative location is going to be
f vector
and the location is going to be minus
39.56
f for the x for the y
1.75 f and last but not least 64.
point zero f on the z axis now relative
location if i hover over does it have an
explanation no but the relative location
is basically location relative to the
parent of this component so the first
person camera's position will be
relative to the get capsule or the
capsule component i'm also going to say
here first person camera and b use pawn
control rotation equal to true
we talked about this in our previous
videos in i don't i cannot remember
exactly which tutorial that was but i
demonstrated like when we don't use the
pawn control rotation when we use the
pawn control rotation so basically this
is the
this gives the control over the rotation
of the pawn so that is it
next we are going to create a mesh
component that will be used
that we are going to view from the first
person and that is the hands mesh so
hands mesh is going to be equal to
create default
so default sub object type is going to
be use skeletal mesh component so mesh
component there you go
and over here it's going to have texts
in the parentheses and for the text over
here we're going to say character mesh
so moving forward after that we're going
to only make the owner see those hands
what does that mean that means the
following so hands mesh from here set
only owner c
and from there we are going to set that
to be equal to true this will make only
the owner or us having this component
see those hands and this is without this
access it's only set only owner c now of
course this is not mandatory it will not
change the game at all but i'm just
showing you different options that we
have because maybe you're creating a
game on your own and you want some of
these options well
here they are so next i'm going to call
the hands mesh and we're going to set up
attachment and we're going to set it up
on the first person camera
so this is where we are going to attach
these hands on the first person camera
that is attached on the capsule
component that we already saw next we
are going to say hands mesh and from
here i'm going to say cast dynamic
shadow so cast dynamic shadow is equal
to false this is self-explanatory it
will not cast any dynamic shadows
it will also over here so hands mesh
cast shadow it's also going to be false
because why we don't need all of this
you know
again this is these are just options
that i'm showing you so next i'm going
to say here hands mesh i'm going to add
relative low rotation excuse me i almost
i wanted to say rotation and location at
once so relation or something like that
f rotator
and over here i am going to set the
value 1.9 f for the x minus
19.19 f for the y and 5.2 for the z-axis
there you go so this is the relative
rotation
i'm also going to say hand mesh and add
the relative location and this time f
vector
it's vector like that
and over here i am going to add minus
0.5
f and i add it in quotes we don't want
to do that in quotes okay
next we are going to say minus 4.4 f and
minus
55.7 f and there you go so this is the
relative location
we are almost done we only need to
create the gun so gun mesh
gun mesh is going to be equal to create
default sub-object of you skeletal mesh
component there you go text over here to
give it a name so the name is going to
be gun you know like
i don't know like
some hood gangster gun okay so gun mesh
from here we're going to say set
only owner c
here it is true
and only the owner will see the gun same
as what we did with the hands argon mesh
so it's gun mesh gun mesh there you go
cast
dynamic shadow is equal to false then
our gun mesh
from here
cast shadow is also going to be equal to
false there you go
and our muzzle location and gun offset
that's the only thing that we need to
also create so gun mesh
actually the muzzle location not the gun
mesh so muzzle location is going to be
equal to create
default sub object you seen component
and text over here
and for this one i'm going to say muzzle
location or basically the location from
where the bullet is going to come out
our muzzle location set up attachment
we're going to attach it on the gun mesh
there you go and our muzzle location
from here set relative location is going
to be f vector so f
vector and one more parentheses so the f
vector 0.2 f
48.4 f and minus
10.6 f there you go
argon offset
is going to be equal to f vector
and the value is going to be 100 f for
the x 0.0 for the y and 10.0 f for the
z-axis now notice over here we did the
set up attachment for all these
components except for the gun mesh now
for the gun mesh we didn't do the
for the gun mesh we didn't do the
setup attachment over here inside of the
constructor instead we are going to do
it here in the begin play so over here
we're going to say gun mesh and from
here attach to component and we're going
to attach it to the hands mesh
and we're going to say over here f
attachment
transform rules and over here we're
going to say snap to target not
including scale and last but not least
text and over here we are going to say
grip point now the reason why i did it
in the begin play is because doing it in
begin play
is safer because the skeletal mesh is
not yet created here in the constructor
so it can happen that this will not work
but when we do in the in the begin play
it will work now i will talk about this
f attachment transform rules what is
this grip point and all of that stuff in
the next video because this video is
already getting long not
what i plan to do but i just want to
compile everything make sure that we
don't have any errors because you know i
want to make sure that everything that
we typed is okay and it's not okay so i
have an a problem over here
on line 40 in the dot h i'm missing
comma in the variable declarations let
me just quickly go here 40
okay here it is after our blueprint read
only i need to add comma
and you know you can forget things
because you type too fast you are a
perfect programmer like i am and all
that stuff just kidding but anyways you
get the point so this is basically it
for this video in the next video i will
explain what this is we will create a
blueprint out of this we will continue
to code and all of that stuff if
something is not clear just make sure
that you ask in the comment down below
but all of this that we did so far is
nothing new we already know how to
create components if you went through
any of my tutorials and all of that
stuff so uh yep fire here from
you already know that you're on the
channel you're on the website or
whatever make sure to check out the blog
and i will see you guys in the next
video what is up my game dev gangster
ronios in the previous video we stopped
over here with the attaching the gun
mesh and i said that i will explain what
this is so basically what does this mean
is that we are going to attach the gun
mesh on the hands mesh and these are the
rules that we are going to use for that
attachment so snap to the target not
including scale so the scale is not is
going to be untouched for the gun so if
we set the scale 100 by 100 for the gun
it's not going to be touched no matter
what the scale of the hand's mesh is now
what is this grip point well basically
the grip point is where we are going to
attach the gun mesh on the hands mesh
what does that even mean well that means
if i go over here and this is where the
hands are located so in the first person
folder character and then mesh and these
are the hands so if i double click these
hands
we are going to open them right here now
if we go into the skeleton of these
hands you will notice over here that we
have something called a grip point look
at that so this is that grip point and
if i come closer to the hands where the
grip point is you see this is where it
is going to be attached now in one of my
previous tutorials
i have
shown you how we can create our own
custom
snapping socket name or whatever
basically you just you know choose where
you want to create it then you
right-click and then you add a socket
and you give it a name the name is
important because here in the code
you're going to reference that name so
that you attach your desired component
on that
on that socket so this is what we are
doing and this is where this grip point
is so this is where the
weapon or the gun mesh is going to be
attached now in order for us to
demonstrate that we do need to
create a blueprint so over here inside
of the content we can right click and
create a new folder for blueprints
and for this bad boy i'm going to go
inside create a blueprint class that is
going to inherit so here all classes we
are going to say monster shooter
character so this is the one that we are
going to inherit and i'm going to say bp
underscore
monster shooter character there you go
and double click this bad boy open him
you know in visual studio i in visual
studio in the editor not the visual
studio so we need to open him in the
editor so over here there you go so we
have the
character mesh this is the mesh the
the one that comes by default these are
our hands that we are going to use and
attach so basically over here for our
hands i am going to choose the hands let
me just find them mannequin hands or
arms here they are this is what we want
now i'm also going to attach the i'm
going to attach the blueprint for the
animation for these and this is going to
be first person anim there you go which
is automatically going to position them
right here as you can see
now when it comes to the gun we also
need to go over here let me just compile
and save that so go over here for the
gun and we need to search the gun so let
me just find it here is the gunny gunny
and you know compile and save that so
there you go so this is where my gun is
going to be and i believe the gun should
be a little bit more behind
i think
i'm not sure 100 but let's go over here
inside of our map and what i'm going to
do also here in the c plus plus class
i'm going to right click and create a
new c plus plus class and click here to
show all classes and filter for the game
mode
and i want to inherit from the game not
the game mode base but the game mode and
i'm going to click here next and i'm
going to call this one monster
shooter game mode
simple as that or monster shooter
underscore game mode
this i'm going to call monster shutter
game mode and i am going to click here
create class
which is of course going to do you know
all of the heavy lifting and whatnot and
yada yada yada you get the point and all
of that stuff
so let us just wait for it and i can
sing to you all this time
reload everything
now the reason why i have you know the
reason why i
created our own game mode is because we
need to create a blueprint out of it so
let's go here into the blueprints and
right click blueprint class and filter
for my
monster shooter game mode here it is and
i'm going to say bp underscore monster
shooter underscore game mode
so that we can go here inside of our
settings and then maps and modes and
change the default game mode to our own
so bp monster shooter game mode so that
we can also change the default pawn
class to our bp monster shooter
character now the reason for that is now
when we hit the play button to actually
run the game our game character is going
to be the one that's going to be spawned
but let me just click on this character
over here for whatever reason where is
the character so first person character
here he is i can delete this we don't
need him
over here
i can have this one over here for
spawning the character this is the start
of the character right
so yeah basically as i said when we run
the game our own character is going to
be spawned
and we can test that out by hitting the
play button and there you go so if i
eject myself we are going to see that we
have spawned the character look at that
he is being spawned and look at where he
is
where the weapon is being spawned it's
right in the socket that i showed you a
moment ago so let me just find it it was
in the first person not ppp fps
actually let me just go here in the
content and then first person and then
fps weapon and then meshes and here it
is actually this is the gun you know i
forget where this is so excuse me for
that one so it's
first person
and character and then mesh and here it
is finally finally i know where it is
and when we go into skeleton again
having the grip point if i zoom in on
the grip point and i press the f to go
directly to the grip point you see it's
in the hand and if i go here in the map
voila there you go he is already
spawned here in the map so this video is
more about explaining what you know is
happening and all of that stuff so in
the next video we are going to start to
code the movement of our character then
we're going to start creating the level
and all of that part or that stuff and
yada yada if something was not clear
when it comes to this video and the
explanations that we did and what is you
know a socket and all of that stuff just
make sure you ask in the comment down
below and i will see you guys
in the next video where else i'm going
to see i'm going to see in jail because
you know i i don't go to jail you go
and uh yeah so we cannot see each other
i will see you in the next video i'll
write it in my game dev gangsta roni oh
now we are going to create the movement
for the player because even if i hit the
play button try to move nothing is
happening you get the point so we are
going to go into the project settings in
here for the input we have everything
already predefined but we don't need all
of this so over here i am going to hemp
jump and fire but reset vr no no i don't
need that so over here for the fire i'm
also going to remove all of this here we
only need the left mouse button nothing
else for the jump we also need the space
nothing else so all of this right here
can be safely deleted
we are going to have move forward but
for the move forward we're going to have
ws up and down
all of these others you know we don't
need them why should we
for the move right we need the a and the
d
that's all so let's go over here
remove all of this remove remove
for the turn and turn rate so basically
this over here
we don't need the turn rate like this so
we can simply delete it here we have the
lookup rate and the lookup so lookup
rate i'm also going to delete we need to
turn and look up so the turn has the
mouse x and the look up has the mouse y
and all of this right here this is what
we need of course i can also delete the
up and down or add here left and right
arrow key that is totally up to you but
what is the next step is to go inside of
our script inside of our cpp and over
here set up player attachment so setup
player input component basically to bind
the functionality to input so what we
need to do over here is we need to call
the player input component so component
like that and we are going to bind the
action
jump is the first one that we are going
to do ie pressed so when we press the
jump button inside of this i am going to
call let me just see over here
i almost tried to search for the jump
functionality but we have the a
character that colon colon i almost said
dash jump there you go so this is
already built into our character i can
copy this
and paste it here so now i'm going to do
that for the e do that do it for the e
released
and over here i'm going to say stop
jumping so when you release the button
we're going to stop the jumping simple
as that next i'm also going to take our
player input component and bind the
action and the action is going to be
over here fire so fire the section is on
fire anyways when we press the i when ie
is pressed inside of this we want to
call the fire functionality which is
this one over here we're not going to
code it right now but as i said when we
go through things that we want to do i
don't want to you know just skip this
and then later on when we actually want
to shoot i come back oh we also need to
bind the component no i might forget and
stuff like that so i'm going to do it
right now
you can do some ue log for example
just to print out to see if this
actually works but we know that it is
going to work
i'm also going to take the player input
component and we are going to bind i
bind the axes so bind axes and this time
is going to be move forward axis inside
of this and we're going to set here our
move forward so simply copy this here
and add the and sign there you go
next i'm going to copy this and paste it
down below because this time we have the
move right so move right and also
calling the move right function
last but not least we have two more so
i'm simply going to copy these and paste
them over here so one is going to be the
turn the other one is going to be look
up there you go and over here we are
going to call the turn at rate and over
here we're going to call look at rate
simple as that so this is how we bind
and this is not the first time that we
are doing this so we already know how to
do it now here inside of move forward we
are going to test if the value which is
this parameter over here so if the value
is not equal to
0.0 f meaning we are actually pressing
the button then we are going to say add
movement input and we are going to say
over here get actor
forward vector and comma here and pass
the value so that we know where we are
going
you can assume what we're going to do
for the move right the same thing so
copy over here but this time we're not
going to say get actor forward vector
instead over here we're going to say get
actor
right vector because we are always right
now over here
we are going to calculate delta for the
frame of the turn so what we are going
to do over here is we are going to say
add controller
yaw input
and we are going to use the rate that is
the parameter over here so using the
rate multiplied with the turn rate
and then we're going to multiply that
with the get world and from the world
we're going to get the delta seconds
like this
and as i said this is going to calculate
the delta for this frame from the rate
information which is going to make it a
little bit smoother and going back over
here pasting this the look rate but this
time it's not going to be add controller
yaw input it's going to be the pitch
input so over here i'm going to say
pitch input and again we're going to use
the rate over here the parameter but
this time it's not the turn rate it's
the look up rate that we are going to
use and multiply that with the world and
delta seconds so ctrl shift b to compile
all of this and make sure that we didn't
do any oopsies which is the case there
you go let me just turn off my volume
because i don't want you to hear this
it's embarrassing and whatnot just
kidding but you get the point so over
here we bound the functionality we know
already what this is and in case some
beginner is watching this what is this
jump what is this fire this move forward
well it's basically this functionality
over here so this is the jump this is
the fire move forward move right turn
and all of that stuff so we are binding
these functions
to those you know to those axes and
inputs which means when we press the
space bar you see over here for the
jumper let's do it for the move forward
so when we press the w or s key then we
are going to execute the move forward
the move forward function which is this
one right here
and we can go inside of our editor and
we can test it out so if i hit the play
button you see
i can rotate now look up and down and i
can move forward look at that i can also
jump you see i have i'm jumping look at
that jumpy jumpy jumpy jumpy jumpy jumpy
jumping jumping jump you get the point
i'm jumping so there you go so look or
we can turn we can look up we can look
down i can move backwards forward left
and right and there you go so basically
this is how easy it is to set up the
moon this is for you who are beginners
and watching this and i know this is not
a complete beginner tutorial but i
cannot prevent beginners from watching
it for whatever reason
you know i cannot put some wall
internet wall that doesn't allow you to
do that but you get the point anyways if
something is not clear what we did over
here as i said and already explained so
we only bound the axes that we have over
here inside of our project setting so
move forward that is the name if here
the name is movement so if we change
from move forward to movement
over here we will also change from move
forward to movement so those names need
to match up and then over here this is
just the function that is bound to that
axis or action that's all there is to it
so when we press the appropriate buttons
that we have designated for move forward
move right turn look up
these appropriate functions that are
bound to those axes or actions will
execute will execute so there you go
if something's not clear ask in the
comment down below i will not help you
out i will just ignore your comment i'm
just kidding i will try to help you out
as best as i can and i will see you guys
in the next video moving forward now
that we have our character and he is
moving let us create the projectile
before we can start shooting and in
order for us to do that we need to go
over here inside of our c plus files and
all that stuff so we are going to right
click and go here new c plus plus class
that is going to inherit from the actor
and from there we're going to click on
next and from here instead of my actor
i'm simply going to call it projectile
and this is going to be the projectile
you can also call it bullet or however
you want to call it okay that is up to
you you can call it carl kenny i don't
know but anyways i'm going to call it
projectile so let me just lower my
volume so that we don't hear all of
those noises when you know something has
compiled and all of that stuff let's go
over here reload everything inside of
our cpp file or actually in the visual
studio and right here below our tick so
this is where we are going to create our
own properties
and we are going to create a new
property and this one is going to be
visible
defaults only
and from there we are also going to set
it into the category which is going to
be equal to projectile and this is again
when you want to locate it inside of a
blueprint you can find it under the
projectile category so over here i'm
going to say class u sphere component
and from there i'm going to call it
collision sphere which is going to and
it's not cp it's collision sphere and
this one is going to be the sphere that
we are going to use to detect collision
with the player and other components in
the game so next we have the u property
and this one is going to be visible
anywhere and this one's going to be
blueprint
read only and it's going to be category
equal to movement and this one is going
to be class
u projectile movement component so we
are going to use the projectile movement
component to propel the projectile to
move and i'm going to call it projectile
movement there we go
next we are going to create a u function
and this one is going to be our
detection for the hit and over here i'm
going to call it void on hit and it
takes a lot of these parameters as you
already know so you primitive
component which is a pointer hit
component it also takes an actor which
is you know also a pointer other actor
that we are going to test if we you know
hit or who is the other actor that we
hit you
primitive component which also is a
pointer other component
and then in 32
other body index and bool b
from
sweep and last but not least constant f
hit result
which we are going to call hit now of
course we don't need all of these
parameters but they are mandatory for us
to
well create or to declare this function
so we need to do it
and also the last step we are going to
have a u property
not proper two its property and this one
is going to be edit anywhere and it's
going to be a float damage value by
default it is going to be equal to 20.
now this damage value is going to be the
damage that we are going to deal to the
enemy
when we hit it and over here i'm going
to go and click on so right click on on
hit and from here create declaration
inside of the c plus plus file so over
here inside of the c plus plus
automatically this will be created so we
don't have to you know type this out on
our own now when it comes to the cpp
file we know that over here we are going
to implement everything so right below i
am going to include everything that we
need to include i'm also going to
include over here so i'm going to say
include and this one is going to be
enemy.h now we still didn't create the
enemy so i am going to simply comment
this out otherwise we will have issues
but i'm going to leave it there so that
later on when we actually create the
enemy we know that we need to include it
because again
i don't like to go back and forth every
single time oh we created an enemy let's
go and include it and all of that stuff
so over here inside of the constructor
for the projectile we are going to say
our collision so collision sphere is
going to be equal to create default sub
object of u
sphere component and that's your
component we are going to give it a name
with a text over here so the name is
going to be sphere
collision
and the sphere component we are going to
set the initial radius to 20 so i'm
going to say
collision sphere and from here init
radius or in its sphere radius we're
going to set that to 20 as i already
said it's 20 f not 20 point f 0.
i'm also going to set the sphere to be
the root component so i'm going to say
root component is equal to the collision
sphere there you go which is going to
set the sphere as the root of all other
components that you are going to add to
the projectile
now for the projectile movement so
projectile movement is going to be equal
to
create default sub-object of you
projectile movement and from there give
it a text or basically a name
which is inside of a text and i'm going
to call it projectile
movement
now right here below over here i'm going
to say projectile movement and we are
going to say updated component is going
to be equal to collision sphere or
basically what does this mean so it's
collision
sphere
not let me just take it from here and
copy and paste it so the updated
component basically means who is the
projectile movement moving so who is he
moving he's moving the collision sphere
which is the root component which is
going to move all other components that
are below it
also over here our projectile movement
we are going to set initial speed to be
equal to 3 000 because we want our
projectile to be fast as a you know
something that's fast projectile
movement from here max speed is also
going to be equal to 3000 because this
is power level over two thousand it's
not over three thousand because it is
you know
you get the point projectile movement we
are going to say b rotation follows
velocity is going to be equal to true so
rotation follows velocity this is
self-explanatory the projectile will
rotate according to the velocity and our
projectile movement
from here we're going to say b
should bounce is going to be equal to
true so we are going to be able to
bounce now i'm also going to set the
initial life span of the projectile
which is going to be here so initial
life span that's going to be equal to
three seconds which means if we don't
hit anything
after three seconds the projectile will
be destroyed
simply after three seconds that's all
there is to it now over here inside of
begin play this is where we need to
connect so our collision sphere and from
here we need to say on component begin
overlap
add dynamic
and over here is where we are going to
connect this function so i'm simply
going to copy it
and from here i'm going to say this and
then and sign and paste the function
that we want to provide over here so
again we need to do this in on the
gameplay because if we do it inside of
the constructor it is not going to work
if i don't forget when we create the
enemy
i will test it out by simply you know
just to demonstrate what happens if we
call it inside of the constructor as
opposed what happens when we call it in
ambiguity play but we also did this
numerous of times in my other tutorial
so it's not something new that we didn't
do so far so ctrl shift b
for this to compile so let us just wait
for this to compile let's see if i have
any oopsies and i don't so build one
succeeded there you go
so what i'm going to do now is go and
create a blueprint from this because in
the next video we are going to start to
shoot it so inside of blueprints i'm
going to right click and blueprint class
and i'm going to filter for projectile
and here it is and from there i'm going
to say bp
tile
and
go inside of the blueprint so that we
can you know add everything what we need
are we in the viewport yes we are what
i'm doing so i'm in the viewport so here
we have the collision sphere what i'm
also going to do is attach the
i'm going to attach a static mesh
component so over here i'm going to say
static mesh there you go it's simple as
that and this is going to be our
projectile mesh now of course i can also
create this from the blueprint but you
know actually from the code but i'm also
going to demonstrate how you're going to
mix blueprints in code because this is
what happens all the time with unreal
engine so you need to mix blueprints in
code it's simple as that now over here
for the static mesh i'm going to filter
for projectile first person projectile
it's a huge sphere so over here i'm
going to click on the lock icon and set
the scale for or for all three axis to
0.1.1
and
0.1 so there you go now this is it when
it comes to creating the projectile we
still cannot test it out because i don't
want to make this video too big and
stuff like that
it's already 10 minutes and so on and so
forth so starting from the next video we
are going to
see how this projectile is going to work
how we are going to propel it and all of
that stuff but if something is not clear
when it comes to creating the projectile
just make sure that you ask in the
comment down below now all of this here
that we did it's nothing new maybe the
projectile movement but you can you know
just read from the functions or what we
did
they are self-explanatory but again if
something's not clear make sure that you
ask and i will also help you out in the
next video we are going to start
shooting the projectile i will see you
guys then now that we have the
projectile we can put it or add it to
the monster character and use it for our
shooting so over here inside of our dot
h file right after we create all of this
look at rate and all of this stuff we
are going to create new variables and
they are going to be public so one is
going to be you property and this one is
going to be edit defaults only and i'm
going to say category
is equal to not gotta go ru category is
equal to projectile
now what i'm also going to do or how am
i going to declare this this is going to
be rt sub class so sub class not sub k
sub class of
and over here i'm going to say class a
projectile and i'm going to call it
projectile simple as that and it's with
one r and they are both lower case or
right basically one r and it's lowercase
not both
so moving forward we are also going to
add the sound that we are going to play
when we shoot so over here i'm going to
say your property and this one is going
to be added
anywhere and i'm going to call it or set
here blueprint read write i'm also going
to set the category to be equal to
gameplay and this was going to be our
class u
sound base which we are going to call
fire
sound or shoot sound or however you want
to call it
and moving forward we are going to
create another you property
and this one is going to be edit
anywhere blueprint read writes a
blueprint
read write
category so category is going to be
equal to gameplay and this one is going
to be our class u anim montage which is
a pointer and we're going to call it
fire animation which is basically the
animation that we are going to use to
preview when we shoot so when we shoot
this is the animation that's going to be
played now over here we're going to say
class u anim instance which is a pointer
and i'm going to call anim instance this
i'm going to call it
next we are going to have a class u
world and i'm going to call it world and
it's a pointer so not the parentheses
world like that
f rotator spawn rotation for the
projectile and f vector is going to be
the spawn location
for the projectile so these are the
variables that we currently need now
over here inside of our monster.cpp at
the top we are going to add the includes
so you can just pause the game and add
all the includes as i already said i
mentioned i do this so that we you know
don't have to do it over and over again
or every single time we basically
every single time we
add something new i don't have to go
back oh include this include that so
include the projectile animation enemy
instance kismet gameplay static statics
and the monster shooter game mode i'm
going to ctrl shift b just to compile
this see if i you know made a typo
anywhere but i'm also going to attach
the shooting sound and i'm also going to
attach the projectile and i'm going to
attach the montage or the animation
now for whatever reason it is taking a
little bit too long for this to compile
so i'm simply going to wait or now okay
now it is compiling okay there you go it
has compiled so let's go back here
inside of our first person shooter or
monster character here he is open the
blueprint
and click on the top
object over here you see the top one
this one so that now over here we are
going to have the fire sound the fire
animation and the projectile so the fire
sound is going to be weapon fire so
weapon
fire 2 this is the fire sound the fire
animation is going to be again fire and
over here first person fire montage and
the projectile over here is going to be
the bp projectile simple as that so
compile and save that so now we can go
back inside of our script and do you
know the rest what we need to do now
inside of begin play where we are is
where we are going to get some
references so we're going to say world
is going to be equal to get world so
we're going to get that
we are also going to say our anim
instance and we're going to get that
from them hands mesh so our hands mesh
and from there we're going to say get
anim instance there you go
so this is dynamite instance that we are
going to get and did we add anime
instances yes anime instance why is this
in
stance okay i didn't type it correctly
so anime instance there you go
so now inside of our on fire this is
where we are going to do the fire or
whatever i wanted to sing like that you
know whatever at some point anyways
we're going to test if the world is not
equal to null so if we have the world
because the world is important to us you
are my world i'm your world and we are
important to each other so next over
here i'm going to say spawn rotation is
going to be equal to get
control rotation and this is going to be
the control rotation from the
pawn character or our own character
now why am i testing if the world is not
equal to null just so that we have a
reference to the world because the world
is the one who is going to spawn
the
projectile so we need to have the world
if we don't have it we will not spawn
the projectile our spawn location
is going to be equal to and over here
we're going to perform some tests so
first we are going to say if our muzzle
so if the muzzle location is not equal
to null ptr and this is what we are
testing and if if this allows me to test
it out so i believe this was okay there
you go so null ptr if muzzle location is
not equal to null ptr with a question
mark we're asking this then we're going
to say over here
muzzle location from there we're going
to say get component location
otherwise colon over here we're going to
say get actor
location and there you go plus the spawn
rotation dot rotate vector and we're
going to rotate by the gun
off set and there you go and why is this
giving me if muzzle location not equal
to null ptr
so it's no p t r there you go why is
why was it giving me weird anyways over
here we're testing or we're setting the
spawn location to be equal to we're
first testing if the muzzle location is
not equal to null pointer meaning we
have the muzzle location we have created
it because i told you we are going to
use the muzzle location
to shoot
so that is the location from where the
from where the projectile is going to
fire so that's why we need it so if it's
not equal to null pointer then we are
going to get the location of the muzzle
so if it's not equal to pointer but this
is just in case if we forget for example
or this is a way to secure your code
let's say like that so that you make it
error proof so if it is so with the
question mark essentially what we are
asking is this so we're asking if the
muzzle location if it's not equal to
null ptr like that then over here we're
going to do this we're going to say our
spawn location so spawn location is
equal to and we're going to get that
from the muzzle location else so else
over here if that is not the case so the
muzzle location is equal to null ptr
then we're saying this spawn location is
equal to all of this so essentially this
line of code so from here up to here
is equal to all of this so this is how
you do it i don't believe this is called
a ternary operator i don't you know i
forget the names and i don't even bother
to remember these names because the
important thing is that you know what it
is
maybe for a job interview you should
know what it is if they ask you what is
a ternary operator you should know the
turning operator is this but for your
own development you just need to know
how to use it so don't bother that much
my advice maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm not
comment down below what you think but
anyways
you denote it with a question mark so
you have a condition then you add a
question mark and after that is the
first condition so if it's true this
will be executed call on if it's not
true then this will be executed so again
this right here is equivalent to this
right here so this is what we are doing
now moving forward we are going to set
spawn collision handling override so
over here i'm going to say f actor
spawn parameters and i'm going to call
it actor spawn params
and i'm going to say actor
spawn params is or dot spawn collision
handling overwrite is going to be equal
to e spawn actor
collision handling method column colon
adjust
possible but don't spawn if colliding
what the hell is this teacher you are
confusing me i don't know what it is
well
don't you know just calm down i'm going
to explain so this f actor spawn
parameters defines available strategies
for handling the case where an actor is
spawned in such a way that it penetrates
blocking collision basically when there
is a danger that when you spawn an actor
that will collide
right away with something at that point
where you are going to spawn it well
this defines how you're going to or how
that actor is going to handle that
collision now this adjusts if possible
but don't spawn if colliding
this means that the actor will try to
find a nearby non-colliding location
based on the shape component of course
so it's going to try to find a nearby
non-colliding location but will not
spawn unless one is found so if it's you
know if it sees that something is there
and it can collide with it it will not
spawn it will try to find nearly so near
it
something you know some location where
it will not collide and then it will
spawn there essentially this is what we
are doing
and last but not least we are simply
going to say over here world
spawn actor
and the actor that we are going to spawn
from here we are going to say
a projectile this is the actor that we
are going to spawn and who are we going
to use as a reference well our own
projectile that we attached in the
beginning of this video at the spawn
location using the spawn rotation and
actor spawn
params and there you go so that's why we
need to know if the world is not equal
to null so that we can use it to spawn
the projectile and i can control shift b
just to make sure that i didn't do any
oopsies you see the build has succeeded
now i'm not sure if the sound is going
to be heard because you know i have the
mic at the low input
volume or low input level which means i
have my mic near my mouth so this is why
the sound is now crispy you know
and this is me bragging but anyways that
is the reason why we cannot hear the
shooting but i will hope that it will be
heard from the desktop because i'm
recording desktop and audio at the same
time anyways moving forward
let's go here and test it out so if i go
here in the first person example map
there you go look at that so we are
shooting and it is shooting but we are
not animating and displaying the sounds
so there you go we are shooting and
doing all of that stuff there you go
there you go there you go there you go
we can you see destroy everything and it
is working yada yada yada yada yada yada
but we don't have the shooting sound and
that's and the animation so we need to
go here right below and we need to test
so basically outside of our so outside
of this over here so outside of the if
statement for testing but we can
actually do it inside because it makes
more sense to do it inside we're going
to test if our fire sound is not equal
to null meaning we have attached our
fire sound so we're going to call you
game
play statics
so game play
statics
hopefully it will you know give it to me
there you go play sound at location
there you go this and the fire sound is
the one that we are going to play at the
get actor location there you go so it's
a good idea to actually call the code to
play the sound if you want the sound to
be played and over here if our fire
animation is not equal to null
and our anim instance is not equal to
null then we are going to call the anim
instance from here to montage play so
montage montage underscore play
not player
and it's montage what is it with me
montage underscore play there you go
passing the fire animation and 1.0 f
which is the playback rate so if you
hover over that's the in play rate
basically we're going to play the
animation from the beginning this is
what it means so ctrl shift b and make
sure that this compiles and let me just
lower my volume because i think it is
too loud well not it's a 30 but i think
you will hear it if not you will hear it
guaranteed on your own computer but i
will try to you know at least get the
audio from the desktop there we go
you can hear that we are
shooting and we can also
hit all of these here now of course let
me just go and you know
lower the volume just a little bit so
that we can actually hear what
i'm talking about
projectiles and all of that stuff so
this is how you can use the same code
for your own game to shoot the
projectiles and
yada yada yada if something is not clear
when it comes to this video for the code
that we did over here for everything
that we typed out just make sure that
you ask in the comment down below spawn
rotation we get it from the control
rotation i explained this over here with
a very cool visual example by using if
else statements i've explained the actor
parameters using the world to spawn the
projectile over here if we have the
sound and the animation just play them
and that would be it
anyways
as down below suddenly it's not clear i
will help you out and i will see you
guys in the next video what is up people
so now we are going to create our enemy
because we already have the player he's
shooting so let's go over here in the c
plus plus and
see section or folder and create a new
class that will inherit from the
character and from here i'm simply going
to call it enemy very clever very
creative i'm the most creative person in
the whole world i'm just going to lower
my volume or basically mute my computer
so that we you know don't get some
i don't know how's it called
hearing disability hearing
problems whatever because my you know
speakers destroyed your ears we don't
want that okay we want you to follow the
tutorial so let's go over here and
double click the enemy open it inside of
our visual studio and reload everything
and yada yada yada so in this video i'm
just going to prepare the basic stuff
such as animation and some components so
over here after we create our setup
player input component we are going to
create a new property and this one is
going to be edit
anywhere so anywhere and it's going to
be class u-box component which is a
pointer and this is going to be our
damage collision which is basically
going to be the component that we are
going to use to detect damage dealt to
the player so when the player collides
with this component we will deal damage
to him over here i'm just going to paste
this function you can go and basically
copy and paste it from the player
himself so you can go here inside of the
monster shader character.h
and you can where is it
monster shooter character where do
actually it's in the projectile so in
the projectile you can just copy this
and you can go over here and you can
paste it and from here i'm going to
quick actions and refactoring create the
you know declaration and whatnot so it
is going to create it hopefully did it
create it or did it block there you go
it blocked for a second but it also
created it so over here at the top
we are going to have a few includes we
are going to have more includes later on
don't worry about that so over here we
have the box component a monster shooter
character we will need that to detect if
we have collided with the monster
shooter character
so what's gonna happen inside of our
constructor we're going to say damage
collision is going to be equal to create
default so it's default not defy
default i need to do it again so create
default default sub-object and it's
going to be a u box component and we're
going to give it a name here inside of a
text the name is going to be damage
collision voila there you go we are
going to
set it up or attach it on the root
component so setup attachment on the
root component that would be pretty much
it and inside of our begin play we are
going to bind the function to the on
component begin overlap so damage
collision
and component begin overlap that
add dynamic dynamic there you go this
and the name of the function which is
going to be our a enemy on hit
of course adding the and sign and there
you go
now we can ctrl shift b to compile this
because now we are going to go inside of
our
editor and create a blueprint for it so
the build has succeeded let's go in the
editor
and inside of our blueprints we are
going to right click and go blueprint
class that's going to inherit the enemy
class
and this one is simply going to be bp
enemy
very simple we did this numerous of
times and this is the damage collision
that we already have so what i'm going
to do with the damage collision is i'm
going to set the x to 41
that is the position of it and over here
i'm going to set the box extend on the y
to 60 and on the z to one one two so one
hundred and two
also for our mesh we are going to select
over here our character or the vampire
there you go he is translucent or
transparent not translucent let me just
first do this so on the z axis i'm going
to say minus 85 and rotate him minus 90
degrees and this is how the character is
going to well look like
when it comes to the capsule component
we are going to leave as is compile and
save and why is he you know why can we
see through him well because he's a
vampire first things first and the
second is if we go here in the meshes
and let me just find the material
vampire matte this is what we need so
this material we need to click on this
matte over here and it's not the first
time we were doing this so over here for
the material
we have this blend mode which is
currently set to translucent we need to
set it to masked and apply that and save
it when we do that it will change the
appearance of that material
i don't know that much about materials
and what is going on here but basically
when we do this now we have the we have
the
vampire visible so i can research a
little bit more and explain that in a
separate video if you want me to but you
can also i encourage you to research
that on your own because that's the best
way to learn
now over here i'm going to inside of the
meshes so in the measure i'm thinking
about creating a separate folder yeah a
separate folder new folder and i'm going
to call it enemy or simply yeah enemy
animations
so enemy animations because we are only
going to have enemy animation so why not
put it in a separate folder right click
over here and we're going to go under
animation and we're going to use blend
space 1d
and select the vampire skeleton and this
one is going to be our vampire
idol underscore running there we go
so let's go inside and drag the idle
animation over here this is not the
first time we're doing this by the way
and drag the running animation here i'm
going to change here the sort the
horizontal axis name to speed not spare
its speed and the maximum value can be
three seven five
so now for example if it's over here the
value then he is in the idle if it's
over here he is running you get the
point so this is not the first time that
we are doing this as i already mentioned
so yeah that would be it
we can also go now inside here and
create an animation blueprint so this is
what we want and it will take the
vampire skeleton okay and this is going
to be our bp
enemy
enemy underscore animation
and for this one what i'm going to do is
i'm going to add a variable
and that one is going to be the speed
variable which is going to be a float
there you go compile and save that
i'm also going to right click over here
and create a state machine so state
machine is going to be my new state
machine and i'm going to call this state
machine vampire
movement we can also call it simply
movement that can do i'm going to plug
this in even though we don't have
anything but we can go over here and now
we can right click and create a new
state this is going to be idle
underscore walk or
basically backslash walk or underscore
or
what's with me and the underscore idle
walk or idle running this is what i
wanted to say this whole time
so going back over here
for the result i'm going to use the idle
running which is our blend space 1d plug
it in over here and plug in the speed
over here now the speed variable we are
going to change that so i'm going to
compile and save that so that now
automatically we see that the vampire
has changed his state from the t pose to
the animation pose but we are later on
when we add later on in the next video
when we start to add more variables to
our enemy we are going to code the speed
movement inside of our event graph over
here so we're going to do that and we're
going to get that from the script we're
going to see all that don't worry about
it just over here for the enemy and the
mesh character for the anim class we are
going to search for the
bp enemy animation so that now if i
compile and save and take the enemy so i
need to find his blueprint which is
inside of the blueprints an enemy and
there you go
so now we have the enemy who is right
here i can move a little bit down
just take this here the snap sizes
something like this
and there you go
so if i hit the play button we will see
the enemy who is behind us and he is
being animated of course he is not doing
anything to us because he's not
detecting us he's not doing you know
yada yada what not we're going to start
to code that from the next video at his
ai site so that he can see us and then
run towards us and all of that stuff if
something was not clear when it comes to
this video make sure that you ask in the
comment down below but basic things over
here just creating the damage collision
over here also adding or binding the
function to the on component begin
overlap and then creating animations
it's not the first time if you followed
any of my unreal engine tutorials i
covered this a lot
so yeah but of course if something's not
clear ask i will answer i will see you
in the next video
what it up guys in the previous video we
created the enemy this is enemy look at
the enemy this is the enemy and we
created his animation so now we can
continue coding the enemy to add some ai
functionality now so far in a lot of the
videos that i did when it comes to the
enemy
ai
i have used these colliders like a
sphere color collider or a box collider
or collision that is so that we can
detect when the player gets or touches
that collider then we know that the
player is closed we can attack him and
so on and so forth this time i'm going
to use ui perception component which is
going to allow the enemy to simulate
senses such as scythe and hearing and so
on and so forth so let's go here inside
of our enemy.h file and right here below
this right here you function on it and
yada yada we are going to add all the
components that we need but before we do
that we do need to go over here inside
of our
dot build file here it is monster
shooter dot build file so this is the
one that we want so it's under source
over here and then monster shooter like
that you need to find the dot build file
for your project and over here inside of
this public dependency module names
click here enter to separate them on the
second line and over here after the last
one that you have so my is head mounted
display you're going to add comma and
then you are going to paste here this ai
module so paste it like this if you
don't do it it will not work no matter
what other code we put in so you need to
in quotes paste this ai module so now
that we have that out of the way we can
go back over here inside of the
enemy.h file and i can start typing so
first i want to add the u property and
this one is going to be visible so it's
visible
defaults only and this one's going to be
category
enemy there you go and this one is going
to be class u
a i perception component which is a
pointer and i'm going to call it ai per
comp there we go
so what the hell is this teacher what is
this ui perception component well ui
perception component is used as i said
to implement senses for an actor for
example
site so that it can see
or hear so that it can hear and that
kind of stuff so this is used as an ai
component
so next we are going to create another
ui property or u property not ui but u
property we're going to have it visible
defaults only category enemy this one is
going to be class u a i sense config
underscore site which is a pointer and
i'm going to call it site config
it's config there you go so what is this
uai sense config site whatever well
this conflict is used to configure the
ai perception component for site
detection so this particular one is used
to configure the site detection for the
uai perception component
next we are going to create a u function
so you function like that and this one
is going to be void unsensed and it
takes a constant t
array of actors so a
actor which is a pointer by the way and
over here close the curly bracket and
have here and sign update actors this or
updated not update excuse me updated
actors this is a function
that will inform us if any actors are
detected by the uai perception component
or by ai perception component so this is
the one and i'm going to go here quick
actions and refactoring create the
definition inside of our dot cpp file so
that you know yada yada yada we don't
have to go and type it out ourselves
so next what do we need for our
functionality well next we need you
property and over here this one is going
to be visible so visible anywhere and
the category so category is going to be
movement
and for this one i'm going to call f or
we're going to declare f rotator and
enemy rotation is the name for the f
rotator next i'm going to just copy this
over here because we're going to do the
exact same thing but this time we're
going to have an f vector and this one
is going to be our base location because
the enemy is going to be able to go
and try to attack the player
but if he doesn't find the player then
he is going to go back to the base
location basically when he detects the
player he will run towards him when the
player runs away from his site
then he is going to go back to his to
his location this is essentially what we
are doing
so this is for the base location next we
are going to have another u property so
i'm just going to copy this and paste it
over here so we're going to have another
visible anywhere but this one we're also
going to use it as a blueprint read only
we will see why basically i can tell you
right now for the animation and we will
see how this is going to work f vector
and this one is going to be the current
velocity of the movement so the current
velocity of the enemy
another u property that is going to be
visible anywhere category is going to be
equal to movement this is going to be
float movement speed self-explanatory
for what we are going to use it another
function that we are going to have is a
void set
new rotation which takes an f vector
target position and an f
vector current so current position has
two parameters to determine the new
rotation we're also going to have a
boolean
back to
base location to determine if we should
go back to the base location or not
another f vector which is going to be
our new location to determine what is
the new location where we should move to
and our float distance so distance
squared there you go
another over here you property so pro
property there you go which is going to
be edit anywhere not anywhere but
anywhere and this is going to be
blueprint so
blueprint
read
only this one is going to be our health
so float
health which is going to be equal to
100.0 f
and last but not least we are also going
to have another u property i'm going to
copy this over here paste it over here
this is edit anywhere this is going to
be float damage
value by default it's going to be equal
to 5 f and last but not least we're
going to have a public function and this
one is going to be void deal damage so
that we can deal damage to the player
float damage amount as the parameter or
basically not to deal damage to the
player this is for us to be dealt with
damage so the enemy will be dealt with
the damage and over here we have the
damage amount parameter don't worry
about these right now because we will
you know code them later on use them
later on for the moment what did i tell
you what did i click over here
cancel cancel okay there you go so quick
actions and refactoring create there you
go
and last but not least for the deal
damage as well quick actions refactoring
create you know signature whatnot and
hopefully come on hurry it up and it
will create the definition for us
i don't know why is it taking so long so
i will have to sing well i wanted to
sing but you see what happened anyways
you get the point so
we are pretty much done with setting
things up we do need to go now inside
the dot cpp file here at the top right
below all of these other includes we
need to include perception ai perception
component and perception ai site config
or a i sense config excuse me so make
sure that you
include these two or otherwise it is not
going to work so over here right below
the damage collision is where we are
going to call our ai per component or
perception component that's going to be
equal to create default sub object of
u
a i perception component and we're going
to call it here so it pass a text to
give it a name and the name is going to
be ai perception component
there you go
next we are going to have our site
config which is again going to be equal
to create default sub object of type of
u a i
sense
config
so sense config underscore
site there you go
and over here pass a text parameter and
inside of the text parameter we do need
to pass the
site config
name
so that we know what it is now we need
to configure this site config so that
the perception component knows
what
to do
so our site config and from here we're
going to say site radius so the radius
where the enemy will be able to see the
player it's going to be 1250
f so floats and our site config from
here lose sight radius so
where the player needs to go or how far
away he needs to go so that the ai
perception will lose sight of him well
that value is going to be equal to i'm
just going to copy this and from here
it's going to be equal to one thousand
what what i thought pounds one thousand
two hundred and eighty
also we are going to add to the site so
our site config and the
peripheral or peripheral
you get the point peripheral vision
angle degrees that's going to be 90
degrees so
the peripheral i i don't know how to
pronounce it
peripheral vision you get the point it's
90 degrees
and again site config
are detection by affiliation of the tech
it's the detection by affiliation and we
are going to say dot b detect enemies is
going to be equal to true our site
config so site config and from here
detect by
affiliation.be detect friendlies that is
also going to be true and last but not
least site config and from here
detection by affiliation so same thing
if it allows me now to complete so
detection by affiliation dot detect
neutrals
is also going to be true this is a
self-explanatory it is going to allow
the side coughing to detect the enemies
the friendlies and the neutrals but
since we only have our player we are
going to you know detect the player
next over here i'm going to say site
config and from here set max h to be
equal to 0.1 f what the hell is the
maximum age well age specifies the time
by which the stimuli
or what has been detected so the
detected actor by this site conflict
when he will be forgotten
so how much time will take for him to be
forgotten zero means never so zero means
never and he will never be forgotten
just like my you know
your girlfriend my
never mind uh
moving forward so he will never be
forgotten if it's zero 0.1 after point
one of a second he will be forgotten
which means then the enemy will go back
towards his base location and all of
that stuff
next we need to call the ai perception
component and we need to configure
census or configure the sense and we are
going to pass over here the site config
the one that we have just created over
here next i am also going to call a i
perception component so it's actually
per comp there you go
and we are going to set the dominant
sense
to be the site config and here we're
going to get the sense implementation so
this is going to be the dominant sense
basically the only sense that we have
configured which is the site sense and
this is how you set if you have multiple
of these maybe you have the hearing
sense and so on and so forth this is how
you can set set the dominant one so is
it site
here or whatever
over here i am going to say ai
perception component on perception
update it and for that i'm going to say
add dynamic so dynamic and from here
we're going to say this passing here and
and we are going to attach this function
on sensed and this is how we are binding
our function to be informed from the ai
perception component when something has
been detected over here we are going to
say current velocity by default is going
to be equal to f vector column column
zero vector this by default so when we
start the velocity by default to zero
movement speed
so over here movement speed is going to
be equal to 375.0
f
and the distance squared is going to be
equal to big number
we're going to see for what we are going
to use this and the big number expands
to it's it's a big number so it's just a
big number and it expands to you know
as i said to a big number but we are
going to use this to detect or to test
for the distance between the enemy and
the player we will see that don't worry
that will come over here inside of our
begin play we are going to say base
location is going to be equal to this
and get the
actor so get actor location
now i'm going to ctrl shift b just to
make sure that we didn't do any oopsies
and yada yada yada and all of this stuff
because we still cannot and we have
something okay i type visibili anywhere
which line of code is that so
shoot enemy line 40 okay let's go over
here
let's go over here where did i type that
out
it's visible it's not like this visible
over here visible anywhere there you go
visible anywhere
visible visible i don't know how to
spell so you know don't judge me anyways
ctrl shift b just to make sure that we
didn't do any oopsies we are going to
call it a stop for this video because
there is a few more things that we need
to code before we can actually test this
out and i don't want to make the videos
overwhelming overwhelming some videos
need to be large but those that don't
have to we have everything prepared next
inside of our tick functionality we are
going to
we are going to create the functionality
to move back to our base inside of our
sensed we are also going to detect if we
collide with something and so on and so
forth then set the new rotation all of
that stuff if something was not clear
what we did so far when it comes to the
ai
perception component and the site config
just make sure that you ask in the
comment down below and i will see you
guys in the next video moving forward
with our enemy ai system we are going to
code this function called set new
rotation because all other ones the
onsen and here what we are going to put
in the tick depend on it so over here i
am going to create a new f vector and
i'm going to call this one new direction
and i am going to calculate that by
taking the target position and
subtracting from it the current position
which are these two parameters that we
have so simply subtracting this from
this so this is going to give us the new
direction where we need to face and i am
also going to take the new direction and
set the z axis of it to be 0.0 f because
again
we care about the x and the y and next
i'm going to take the enemy rotation and
set that to be equal to new direction
rotation so now we have the rotation
from the new direction that we have
calculated by passing the target
position in the current position
so now we can safely call set actor
rotation passing the enemy rotation and
this is going to rotate our this is
going to rotate our actor so over here
inside of our onsens
what is going to happen well we're going
to loop through this updated actors
array and we are going to see if we have
any info or if something has been
detected so we're going to say for int i
which is equal to zero as long as i is
less than the updated actors
that count or actually excuse me num i'm
you so used to unity count and length
and so on and so forth so yeah you get
the point so over here four in i which
is equal to zero as long as i is less
than the updated actors number which is
well this bad boy over here and this
array will contain
information about every actor that's
that's been sensed by the ai perception
component that would be it now over here
we are going to create f actor
perception
blueprint info and i'm simply going to
call it info now this parameter
this parameter is going to get
information about the sensed actor so
whoever we have sensed inside of our ai
perception component this actor or
excuse me this this parameter it's going
to get that information so from here
what i'm going to do i'm going to say ai
perception component so ai per comp and
from here i'm going to say get actors
perception there we go and we need to
pass here updated actors and the element
that's at the i index and passing here
the info there you go
so this retrieves whatever has been
sensed
by the given
whatever has been sent about the given
actor so over here we are looping
through the updated actors and every
actor that we have sensed
this will return information inside of
this info so it will return the
information about that actor desk that
has been sensed in our case we are using
the site so if we have seen i almost
almost want to say saw
seen so i don't know if we saw yeah so
it's more natural so if we saw that
actor we will have information about him
inside of this info
info parameter so over here we can say
if info dot last sensed stimuli and this
is the last sensed actor and the element
that's at index zero so the one that we
have sensed was successfully sensed so
if that is the case then we're going to
do one thing else if he was not
successfully sensed we're going to do
another thing so again going over here
if he was successfully sensed we are
going to say f vector and i'm going to
call it the ir not do or the direction
and that's going to be equal to updated
actors
and the element that's at i index and
from here we're going to say get actor
location and we're going to subtract
from it get actor location which is our
own location and of course the ir it's
not vector y vector every single time
and we're going to say dot z is going to
be equal to 0.0 f
and
what are we doing here so if we
successfully sensed
the last simile so basically the last
actor inside of this information
basically the actor that we are trying
to get from here so if we have
successfully sensed him in our case if
we seen him then we are going to get his
location and we are going to subtract
from it the current location of the
enemy which is going to give us the
direction so next we are going to take
the current velocity and we are going to
set that to be equal to direction get
safe normal
and we're going to multiply that with
the movement speed
what this get safe normal is going to do
it's
going checking if it's
it's basically going to get the length
of this vector but at the same time
checking if it's safe to do so based on
the length of that vector so essentially
getting this direction and multiplying
that with the movement speed so the
direction is where should we face
basically so way where should we face
and let me just get my drawing tool
there you go i have it now
so if the enemy is here and it senses us
over here this direction over here is
going to have a vector that's pointing
towards us like that so when we say the
current velocity is equal to the
direction multiplied with the movement
speed it's going to make sure that that
velocity is facing that direction and
it's going to propel it towards it by
multiplying it with the movement speed
and now over here we can call set new
rotation and we can pass over here
updated updated actors and the element
that's at i index and we can get the
actor location not actor label actor
location and we can pass our own get
actor location again not label but
location
and there you go so this is going to set
the new this is going to set the new
rotation based on the and again over
here you will see that it is going to
rotate the actor by getting the target
position which in this case is the
sensed actor so the one that we saw with
the ai perception and getting our own
current position over here subtracting
these two it's going to get the new
direction and then from there it is
going to rotate our enemy so this is
what it is doing else over here if we
don't have any info about the
that we successfully sensed an actor so
what we are going to do over here is we
are going to say f vector that i'm going
to call direction is equal to base
location subtracting from it the get
actor location so get actor location
there you go so if we didn't sense
an actor meaning we didn't see the
player we are going to go back to the
base location and in order for us to do
that again we need to say the z to be
equal to zero and we're getting the base
or the direction subtracting from the
base location the current direction or
the current location excuse me from the
enemy and over here i'm going to test if
the direction that
size squared 2d if that value and open
close parenthesis if it's greater than
1.0 f
so essentially what i'm doing here this
will get the squared length of this
vector basically that is the meaning so
it will get the length
gets the squared distance between two
points so that is what what does that
mean so it is going to get this squared
length
and if that value is greater than
1.0 then i'm going to say current
velocity is going to be equal to dri so
direction get safe normal so again i'm
going to get the safe normal multiplied
with the move speed
and then i'm going to say back to base
location to be equal to true and from
here set new rotation passing here the
base location passing get the actor
location like that
and this over here needs to have equal
so set equals to true that means that we
are now going to go back to the base
location
because we didn't sense any new actor
and the base location we get its
location over here so the base location
is the initial position where the enemy
is and over here inside of our tick
functionality basically the update
function we are going to check if our
current velocity is not zero so is zero
like that notice the exclamation mark
that we have so we are testing if it's
not equal to zero if that is the case we
are moving and over here we're going to
say new location is equal to get actor
location so location
and from that we are going to add to it
the current velocity
multiplied with delta time so this is
going to be the new location our own
location of the enemy plus the current
velocity by which we are going to move
multiplied with the delta time
if we should go to base location so if
back to
back to base location meaning we should
go back to the base location if that is
the case we are going to first test if
inside of parentheses if the new
location
minus the base location
dot size squared so again we're getting
the size squared if that is less than
the distance
squared
if that is the case we're going to say
distance
squared is going to be equal to
new location subtracting from at the
base location
that
size
squared there you go so this is going to
set the distance squared to this and
it's size squared with open close
parentheses there you go
actually do i need to
yeah only only one there we go
else if it's not
else if it's not and let me just go here
there you go if it's not then we're
going to say current velocity is going
to be equal to f vector column column
zero vector
and then we're going to say distance
squared is equal to a big number again
setting it to the big number and back
to base location is going to be equal to
false
and over here we're also going to set
the new
rotation to the get
actor forward vector
and over here we're going to say get
actor
location so this is going to set the new
rotation outside of all of this so
within this if statement over here we're
simply going to say
set actor location and passing here the
new
location and there you go so this is
going to move us back to the base
location
and basically this right here is going
to move us to the current location that
we are calculating and we are
calculating that well with this over
here so if the new rotation as you can
see all of this here
as long as we're following the player
the current velocity is going to be this
value and as long as we need to go back
to the current location the current
velocity is going to be this value so
over here essentially what we are
testing if our new location
minus from the base location if we are
going back of course so if we should go
back to base location
subtracting from the new location and
testing if the size squared is less than
the distance squared then we're going to
set the distance squared to this value
otherwise we are waiting until else over
here so until this value is less than
this value then we are or actually until
it's greater than this value that means
we have reached the
we have reached our new location which
in this case is the base location
because this all happens inside of the
this all happens over here in the if
statement if we are going back to the
base location
because we need to make sure that we
reached the base location so that
eventually our current velocity will get
to zero because if it doesn't get to
zero we will run forever only if we are
chasing the player we are going to run
forever towards the player trying to get
him and stuff like that but if this is
our base location we chase the player up
to here we need to go back here and this
is where we need to stop and this is how
we are going to calculate so if the new
location minus the base location size
squared is less than the distance
squared then we are going to set the
distance squared to the
new location minus base location size
squared
up until the value where this right here
is going to be greater than the distance
squared meaning not lower but it's going
to be greater
and then we are going to set the current
velocity to zero
again set the distance squared to big
number that's why we need it to be a big
numbers because when we start to go back
then every single time this is going to
for the first initial check this is
going to be less than the distance
squared and back to base location is
false and over here we're going to
rotate so ctrl shift b just to make sure
that we didn't do any oopsies and
everything you know compiles and
it is how it needs to be so build has
succeeded as you can see
now we can go and we can test it out so
if i open my unity editor we will be
able to if i hit the play button
where is the enemy here he is if i get
close to him and he sees me there we go
so he now he saw me and he's rotating to
where i am if i go away and run away
from his sight and he cannot see me
anymore then he is not going to follow
me but you know since
there you go and we finally run away
from him and there you go he goes back
to his base location again if we come
over here his perception is 90 degrees
so he can see us and
you saw what happened so this is his
base location if i run away look at that
so now he's going back to his base
location so essentially this is how it
works just imagine that he has some
invisible
web over here and he can see everything
in this line and basically how i know
that is over here we have determined
that so his sight radius up to which
where he can see is
1250 the lose sight radius
that is the radius where we need to run
away so that the ai perception component
doesn't see us is 1012 280.
and the peripheral vision is 90 degrees
which means and you saw that that the
enemy can even see us if we get over
here so if we get to him like this he
can still see us because he can see 90
degrees that means you know you can see
here and here as well so that is what we
have set up and over here
while we attach that science conflict we
explain all of that essentially what's
happening or where we are detecting all
that it's right here so if we sensed the
player which just happened then we're
going to get the direction based on his
location and our current location and
then we're going to set the current
velocity to that value
you get the point if something is not
clear when it comes to this video make
sure that you ask in the comment down
below and also by the way i've explained
this here when we are going back to the
base location when we you know lose
sight
so yeah that happens over here as well
so when we don't or we cannot sense
anything we set here back to base
location to over here and then we start
running back which i already explained
but if something is not clear make sure
to ask in a comment down below and i
will help you out and i will see you
guys in the next video
what is crackings people so now we have
the enemy who has the sight perception
or basically he can see
he is a bat that can see we are doomed
just kidding but now we are going to
animate him because if you remember when
we got close to him so let me just get
here look at that he's like a you know
silver surfer he's sliding on the ground
which is not something that we want so
we are going to go here inside of the
meshes and actually not in the enemy
animations and enemy animation here it
is if you remember we have over here the
speed value that is set over here on the
blend space for the vampire idol running
now where can we set that well we need
to set that over here inside of our
event graph and that's going to happen
over here at the top i am going to get
the initialize
so this is the one that i want blueprint
or event blueprint initialize animation
first what i'm going to do is i'm going
to get this try get pawn owner and from
here i'm going to cast to bp enemy
and there you go and who am i casting
well i'm going to cast over here the try
to get pawn owner if i hover over this
function does
what the name says it is going to try
and get the owner of this
of this pawn basically getting the owner
of this animation
there we go and
who is owning this animation well the bp
enemy we're casting him to the bp enemy
so from here what i can do is i can
promote this into a variable
and over here as bp enemy simply i'm
going to say bp enemy so again i need to
go here remove this as bp enemy so
remove that part
and over here bp enemy ref so ref is
short for reference so next what we are
going to do well from here we are going
to get rbp enemy
and this is going to happen here in the
update animation so what i'm going to do
here is i am going to get the current
velocity look at that and it's right
here under movement look at this over
here so under movement
we have something called get current
velocity what is this if you remember
i'm quickly going to go back over here
inside of the enemy.h the current
velocity look at this we set or created
a property called current velocity we
set it to be blueprint read only so we
can read it into the blueprint we just
see and we set the category to be
movement this is what it means when you
set the category over here in the code
so when you're searching it inside of
the blueprint so from here current
velocity look at that it's under
movement which we set inside of the code
so now we can from the current velocity
we can get the vector
so vector length
here it is and now that we have the
vector length we can set the speed so
from here i can set the speed this goes
over here voila there you go and this
should be plugged in over here so i need
to compile and save that and now when
the enemy starts moving because in the
code we already know that the current
velocity which is over here we are
changing that value as you can see
so if we have the player in sight we're
setting the current velocity to the
direction get saved normal multiplied
with the movement speed that we already
explained over here if we don't have the
player we are setting the current
velocity
to the safe normal of the direction that
we have over here multiplied with the
movement speed which means now if i go
over here again compile and say make
sure that it is compiled and saved
so if i hit the play button right now
and the enemy sees me and he starts
running look at that he is being
animated and he is running towards me if
he goes back you're going to notice
right now if he loses the sight of me he
goes back
and look at the funny
the funny walk
anyways you get the point and you saw
how now the enemy is being animated if
you have any questions in regards to
this and how we can access
our variables inside of the blueprint
and what does the category mean i mean
again if
how to use it and stuff like that just
ask but we saw a really cool example so
blueprint read only will make the you
know velocity current velocity or any
other variable accessible inside the
blueprint category is where we can find
it inside of the blueprint
and that would be pretty much it i will
see you guys in the next video moving
forward now that we have animated enemy
the enemy can move let us make the enemy
attack the player and vice versa the
player will be able to attack the enemy
so over here inside of our monster
shooter character dot h right here below
our spawn location we're going to create
a new property and this is going to be
edit
anywhere and it's going to be blue
print
read only because we will be or we will
need to get a reference to this value in
the blueprint but we'll see later why so
over here we have a float health that is
going to be equal to 100.0 f and last
but not least we have a public function
that is going to allow us to you know
receive damage so void deal damage and
it is going to be float damage amount
same as what we did with our enemy
so i'm going to right click on this one
and i'm going to create the definition
inside of the dot cpp file but
waiting for the you see so i'm singing
i wanted to charge you five bucks for
that okay
so
here we are inside of our deal damage
and what's gonna happen over here is
that we are simply going to subtract
from the health the damage amount that
we have over here so this one over here
so we're simply going to say health
minus equals the damage amount and the
health is the value that we you know
just added over here there you go this
one over here so we are subtracting from
it the damage amount and i'm also going
to test over here if our health
so if our
health is less than or equal to 0.0 f
that means that the player is basically
dead
so what we are going to do is we are
going to
restart the game when the player dies so
over here restart game but we can just
for the sake of example call here
destroy so destroy after that of course
so after we restart
first things first we will simply
restart the game when the player dies
but just for the sake of example and
testing later on to see if the enemy is
actually dealing damage to the player we
can call destroy over here now same
thing for the enemy we need to go and do
the same thing same thing for i mean we
need to go do the same thing so over
here at the bottom we have already
defined the deal damage functionality so
we are going to say health
minus equals the damage amount so damage
amount that we pass over here and if you
don't remember we already created here
the health and we created here the
damage amount so we're subtracting from
it and if the health gets to the value
so if our health gets to the value that
is less than or equal to our well zero
value then we are going to call destroy
so it's actually destroyed and there you
go this is going to destroy the enemy
now where is this going to happen well
first things first when it comes to the
enemy over here inside of our on hit as
you can see there you go this is where
we are going to detect if we are
colliding with the player and if you
don't remember over here in the damage
collision we have already attached that
functionality so essentially what we are
going to do over here is we are going to
try and cast the other actor so we're
going to say a monster shooter character
who is a pointer and we're going to call
him char and we're going to try and cast
into the a
monster shooter character and we are
casting the other actor so this is the
one who we are trying to cast which is
the other actor that we have collided
with if that succeeds so if char
that means the cast has succeeded we
casted the other actor into the monster
shooter character that means we collided
with the player then from there we can
call the deal damage to apply damage to
the player passing here the damage value
which currently has a value of five so
it will take a lot of hits if the player
assuming that the player has 100 health
it will take a lot of hits
to you know deal any damage to or
actually to to kill the player but you
know it is what it is you can change
that value because we set it over here i
believe we set it to a b at it anywhere
so that means we can go inside of the
blueprint and just you know edit this
value for testing purposes which is
really cool and when it comes here for
the projectile
over here as you can see i've already
included the enemy.h but i have
commented out because at that point of
time where we you know typed out this
include the enemy script was not created
so now we already have over here the on
hit which we have bound over here inside
of the collision sphere of the
projectile and we're going to do the
same thing so we're going to try and
cast into the a enemy who is a pointer
and i'm going to call him enemy and i'm
going to say over here cast into the a
enemy enemy and i'm casting the other
actor
and if that succeeds same as with the
player so if that succeeds if we do have
the enemy meaning that the projectile
has collided with the enemy then we're
going to say enemy and from here we're
going to say deal damage passing the
damage value that we already set for the
projectile
well let me see where it is so where did
i set the damage value
here it is damage value so i set it here
and to be equal to 20. and of course
after we destroy the enemy actually
after we deal damage to the enemy we're
going to call destroy so
if it allows me if i can type correctly
you know so we're going to call destroy
to destroy the projectile so because the
projectile when it touches the enemy it
deals one time damage and then it is
destroyed and removed from the game so
ctrl shift b to make sure that this you
know compiles and it is you
know error free
and there you go build has succeeded so
we can go back inside of the editor
and from here let me just take the enemy
and let's see over here do we have here
it is the damage value just for the
testing purposes i'm going to set the
damage roller to 100 so that it deals
damage automatically and kills me so as
soon as the enemy touches me we are
hopefully going to die there you go and
bam you see where that
we are dead
if i go here see the enemy doesn't exist
actually not that i mean the enemy has
fallen down and we don't care about that
because we're going to restart the game
when we die but the important thing is
that our player is dead because you know
the enemy's damage value was 100 so
we're going to set it back to 5 because
it's not you know we cannot play so
let's try to kill the enemy there we go
and let me just lower my volume so going
back over here lowering the volume even
more to 10 because i don't care about
the volume there you go one two three
hopefully i think there you go
there you go i i want to say hopefully
it will i will kill him soon i didn't
count how many shots but since we have
the damage value of 20 we need to shot
him or shoot him five times in order to
kill him and there you go you saw that
and i can repeat it
just for the you know testing purpose
one two three four and fifth bam and
there you go the enemy is dead basic
math just subtracting from the health
inside of the deal damage so for enemy
and for the player just subtracting from
the hell the damage amount that we pass
here when that value gets to zero or
lower zero destroy it and that will be
pretty much it and over here for the
player we're going to restart the game
we're not going to kill the player but
we will restart the game and we will see
how that works and how we're going to
you know implement that but at the
moment we don't need it starting from
the next video we're going to create the
ui and display visually
the health value of the enemy and the
player and from there we're going to
proceed and wrap up our game if
something's not clear ask down below i
will ignore and just kidding i will
answer and i will help you out and i
will see you guys in the next video whoa
whoa whoa
what it is now moving forward what we
are going to do inside of the blueprints
this is where i'm going to add
the ui i'm not going to create separate
folders because you know we're only
going to have one ui widget so i'm going
to right click in user interface and
we're going to create a widget blueprint
now i'm going to call it bp underscore
ui and this is going to hold so i'm
going to double click it and this ui is
going to hold the player health and it
is also going to hold the timer so first
things first i'm going to take the text
and put it over here which is going to
be the timer the anchor is going to be
at the bottom middle so the x position
is going to be minus 2
48 32 on the y position i think yeah
that is pretty much it size x 5 2 2 size
y 1 4 2 there we go
over here i'm simply going to write
not text block but time call on and zero
this is it for now now i can of course
go over here for the font rubato and
size is going to be 55 there you go is
it 55 or 85 yeah 85 because 55 is very
small
and probably we are also going to align
it in the center and that would be it
when it comes to the time
so next what i'm going to do is take
another text and position it here at the
bottom and this text i am going to set
the anchor at the bottom left corner
and for this text i'm going to set the
position x to 28 position y to negative
181.
the size x is going to be 4 3 7 and the
size y is going to be 73
over here we are going to instead of
text block we are going to say player
health there you go
the
font size is going to be 54 and i
believe that would be it
so next step is to take the progress bar
and the progress bar is also going to
have the anchor at the bottom left
corner the position x for the progress
bar is going to be 28 the position y is
going to be minus 89
i'm going to set the size of the
progress bar on the x to 477
and 60 on the y and that would be it and
over here you can fill it out but for
the color i am going to choose let's go
over here
something like this red color and i'm
going to click ok
and there you go that would be pretty
much it so safe
so now how can we display players health
if you remember inside of our player
health let me just go over here i set
the health value to be blueprint read
only which means that we can read it
from the blueprint but in order for us
to do that we need to get a reference to
it so let's quickly go inside of our
widget back and over here on the graph
i'm going to set this event construct so
i'm going to leave that this i'm going
to remove tick i'm going to remove so
what i'm going to do here for the event
construct i am going to right click over
here and i'm going to get the player
character so this is the one that i want
and from here i'm going to cast to
bp monster shooter character
to the blueprint that our character is
using and i'm going to cast the player
character this bad boy over here so when
the cast succeeds from here i'm going to
promote that to a variable which is
going to give me a reference to the
player character so i'm simply going to
call this one
monster shooter character ref
ref is short for reference this is my
own you know nami convention or however
you know you can call it or whatnot
anyways this is how we are going to get
the reference of the player so now that
we have the reference of the player i
can click on the progress bar and over
here we already know that for the
percentage we can click on this bind
so i can bind and i can create a new
binding or from here i can also just try
to find the health but i'm going to do
it like this go over here
and i am going to call this one
display so display player
health there you go
and
for this one what we are going to do is
getting the reference of the player
character
and the next from here i am going to
drag a note and i'm going to get the
health so here is our health and what i
also need to do is divide the health by
the float as you can see and that value
is going to be 100 and then plug it in
over here why am i dividing the health
value by 100 well it's very simple
because over here the percentage so the
percent value
of the slider goes from 0.0 as you can
see
up to
1.0 so if the health of the player is
for example 90 currently so it has 90 we
dealt damage or you know we were damaged
when we divide 90 by 100 that's 0.9 so
that means over here if i set it to 0.9
you see this is how the health will be
displayed and we can test that out so
i'm simply going to put it back to one
and compile and save but
first things first i'm going to remove
this and remove this there is one more
thing that we need to do i'm like steve
jobs but there is one more thing we need
to go inside of the bp
so our game mode
and inside of our event begin play we
need to
create that widget so from here i need
to say create widget here it is
and the widget that we want to create is
the bp ui
and after we create the widget from here
we need to drag a node and we need to
add to viewport
so add the widget to the viewport if we
don't do this then the widget that we
have just created which is this one over
here it will not be displayed in our
game at all so now if i go back over
here and hit the play button we will see
there you go the widget is being you
know displayed and when the enemy starts
chasing me and when he comes close look
at the health value
so help look at that so there you go
health value he dealt damage a little
bit we can probably there we go he needs
to get too close so what i'm going to do
is go here into the enemy since the
enemy needs to get too close i'm going
to just move the damage collision just a
little bit in front of the enemy so the
enemy doesn't have to get that close to
the player to deal damage of course
this is your own preference if you want
to you know move it a little bit further
or you know put it close that is up to
you if i hit the play button let's try
it out again
so now
what the enemy gets look at that so now
he's dealing damage and you can see i'm
running away and he's dealing damage and
all of that stuff and yada yada yata
anyways you get the point if something
is not clear when it comes to this and
what we did inside of this blueprint
well basically over here
for our health make sure that you ask
otherwise if you don't have any
questions good for you you have learned
how to create games now go go and create
your own grand theft auto go my pupil i
cannot wait to see it and i will see you
guys in the next video moving forward
now that we are displaying players
health let us also display the countdown
timer so essentially what's going to
happen here is inside of our dot h for
the monster shooter game mode right
below the generated body we are going to
have a few variables one is going to be
public and functions as well so first
one is going to be public this is going
to be void
restart so re
restart game play which will take a
boolean
one to determine if we want or if we
have lost we are also going to have a
private function and this one is going
to be void resets level like that
next we are going to have another public
and this one is going to be a variable
so it's going to be you property
and this u property is going to be
blueprint read only so we will be able
to read it inside of our blueprint and
it's going to be our integer timer count
by default i'm going to set that value
to be 300. below we are also going to
have private variables and this one is
going to be f timer handle and i'm going
to call this one countdown timer handle
and that's going to be equal to f timer
handle like that we're also going to
have a void
countdown timer function
and last but not least we are going to
have a public overriding the begin play
so we're going to say void begin
play over right there you go so these
are the functionalities that we have one
for restarting the game resetting the
level and all of that stuff so what i'm
going to do is go here quick actions and
refactoring you know that stuff create
you know definition and all of that
while i'm doing this
finally i'm going to take your five
dollars
i don't know what this is
don't give me your five dollars okay
just you know quit watching this video
and then unsubscribe from the channel
just kidding be subscribed and give me
your five bucks man anyways
here you go so we created everything and
if we go over here i'm just going to
move the begin play at the top because
this is
i simply love the begin play to be at
the top
i know it sounds weird but you know
that's my favorite pose anyways
so include kismet gameplay statics over
here we have the begin play i'm quickly
going to call the super begin play there
you go
and what's going to happen over here is
that we are going to get the world timer
manager so get world timer get world
timer manager and from him we are going
to set the timer
and this is going to be the countdown
timer handle because we need to use the
handle to know which timer we are
setting inside of this
and what is the function that we want to
be called well we want this one over
here
the countdown timer so over here i'm
going to say and sign passing the
countdown timer i'm going to call it
after one second and i am going to set
it to repeat forever after every
second
so essentially what is this well this is
going to call the world timer manager to
set the timer basically this is like a
co routine inside of unity and this is
how we know which
timer handle we have started so when we
want to cancel it we're going to call
this timer handle over here to cancel it
this is the function that i want to be
called which is the countdown timer call
it after one second
and then call it true meaning forever so
call it forever after
every single second so first call it
after one second then after every single
second and that is going to last
forever
ever ever ever ever
and what's gonna happen in the countdown
timer well in the countdown timer we are
and i think i forgot to
restart gameplay i believe
did i create the definition i did but
where is it begin play reset level
countdown timer
where is the restart gameplay
void for whatever reason create
definition the variation could not be
complete following the selected text
does not contain function signature what
we will create it right now so i'm
simply going to copy it and go over here
we have the reset level
and we are also going to have here avoid
a
monster shooter game mode column call on
restart gameplay and over here i'm going
to say bull one as the parameter
for whatever reason i don't know why you
saw it was not you know giving me that
anyways what's gonna happen in the
countdown timer is that we are going to
say timer
count subtract from that minus minus
and if our timer count gets to the point
where it is equal to zero then we are
going to call
the get
world
timer manager and from here we're going
to clear the timer and now we are going
to pass the countdown timer handle
because he is the one who is responsible
essentially he is the one who is
responsible for
for
keeping up with the timer handle and
canceling the timer handle when there is
a need you know to cancel it basically
so that's all there is to it so if you
want to cancel the timer handle you need
to have the timer handle that you
started which is our countdown timer
handle when we want to cancel it so it
will not run anymore then simply call on
the world timer manager clear timer and
simply count down timer handle and there
you go so
the name of the handle and it's going to
start or or stop counting next i'm going
to call restart level so not the game
but restart level this is the one that i
want there you go or reset level excuse
me i said restart but reset
here the reset level is very simple we
are going to have you game play statics
and from here we're going to call open
level passing the world
and passing the name of the level which
is gameplay we still didn't create that
level so we will create it very soon
and well when that happens we are going
to reload that you know gameplay and
it's simple as that now just so actually
right now i'm going to do it right now
i'm going to create it because i don't
want to forget about it so
over here i can create a new folder for
maps and let's go quickly over here file
and new level this is the one with the
default here is where i'm going to you
know add the player and enemy so i just
need to call it gameplay and there you
go so from here let me go into the
blueprints this is the enemy i don't
care this is very small we don't care
about that here we have the monster
shooter character
the or actually we don't need the
monster shooter character here we just
need the player start which is going to
be over here of course after this we are
going to start creating our level don't
worry about that let me just hit the
play button and there you go this runs
this is just for testing purposes so
that you know the code that we have here
calling the game play if it doesn't
exist we will have problems and all that
stuff
here when it comes to restarting the
game we are going to test if we won
so did we win the game if we
well win the game we are simply going to
call here reset level there you go else
if we didn't win the game then we're
going to call
our f timer handle that i'm going to
call timer handle like that or restart
timer handle
get world timer manager from here we're
going to set the timer timer handle and
we're going to call it inside of this
and this is the function that we are
going to call reset level so this one
over here so i'm going to copy it add
the and sign this is the name of the
function and i'm going to call it after
three seconds
so basically if we want we're going to
restart the level immediately
if we didn't win we lost so if one is
false and we're going to denote that
over here so if one is false then we are
going to reset the level after three
seconds and that is going to be pretty
much it now while i am at it over here
inside the monster character cpp let me
just see if everything is yes everything
is imported here at the top so over here
when we die look at that so restart game
when we die i'm simply going to get a
reference to the game mode and do i have
over here my game mode monster shutter
game mode yes i have so i have my game
mode because inside of the game mode
is this function to restart you know the
the game simple as that so over here i'm
simply going to say a
monster shooter game mode and it's a
pointer so i'm going to say my game mode
and that's going to be equal to from
here cast and i'm going to cast a
into the a monster shooter game mode and
who am i casting from you gameplay
statics i am going to get the game mode
like that but we also need to pass here
the world so get the world and there you
go
so now we are trying to get the game
mode if we do have the game mode so if
my game mode so we got a reference to
the game mode we are going to simply say
my game mode
restart game
play that is so restart gameplay and
passing here false why passing false
well passing falls because we died you
see over here if we get killed then you
know we simply need to restart the game
we died and
that's pretty much it so after three
seconds we are going to you know restart
the game so let me just compile this so
ctrl shift b we need to compile this
and the reason why we need to compile it
because now going back inside of our
blueprints there you go everything has
succeeded we are the best coders in the
world so now we can go inside of our
gameplay and we can test it out so we
can see right away if the enemy can kill
us so let me just go here for the enemy
and set the value 100 for the damage
just so that we can see that the enemy
can kill us right away and when it does
okay i have shot when it does bam look
at that it's going to restart the game
and voila there you go the game has been
restarted if i you know
you see this
whatever this is
well over here if we take a look at it's
trying to get the display held for the
player and all of that stuff we can fix
this and we destroy the player it's
trying to access the player to display
the health but we destroy the player we
can fix this by going over here in the
player bpui and before we actually
display the health what we can do is we
can break this pin and over here we can
test is valid
so it will test if the game object or
actually the actor in this case if it's
valid and if that is the case then we
are going to display that health value
otherwise we will not do that so this is
one of the ways how we can protect
ourselves basically the character has
been destroyed it's trying to access a
character or an actor that has been
destroyed it doesn't have access to a
destroyed actor so that's why we saw
that problem so if we try that right now
and if the enemy kills us there you go
we are dead the game will restart there
you go if i you know turn it off now we
don't have that problem that is pretty
much it now over here for the damage
valve i'm going to set that to 5 back
for the enemy and what we need to do is
display the countdown timer because
inside of our you know if you remember
in the game mode over here we are start
starting the countdown but we need to
display that in order to display it it's
very simple over here in the ui in the
event graph
after we get a reference to the you know
player
we need to right click over here and we
need to say get game
mode and we are going to cast to
bp monster shooter game mode and who are
we casting well we are casting the game
mode that we got over here so returns
the current game mode base null if it
cannot be retrieved but if it can
retrieve it it will return it so we're
going to try and cast that one into the
monster shooter game mode and if that
succeeds i'm simply going to promote it
into a variable and from here
i'm simply going to see monster shooter
game mode ref
so this is the monster shooter game mode
reference
and over here inside of our designer for
the time i am going to bind over here so
i'm going to create the binding
and this binding i am going to call
display
countdown timer or display yeah
time countdown actually so time count
down
and what's going to happen over here is
that i am going to get the game mode so
the reference that we have for the game
mode here it is
from the reference i'm going to get the
timer count so timer count because we
set inside of our class over here that
we can get a reference to it so it is
blueprint read only
so now what we can do is i can create
here a string so i can say here append
and this is for the string not for the
array but for the string and i'm going
to say here time and then column and
then space
and i'm going to append the timer count
over here and all of that i'm going to
put over here inside of this returning
node for the time so what this is going
to do it's going to create a string time
then column then space then it is going
to append to it the value of the timer
count and that whole value is going to
be put over here inside of that text so
that text is going to be like this time
call on space and the value of the timer
and we can simply test that out if i hit
the play button look at that 300 299 297
so on and so forth and all of that stuff
when it comes down to zero i'm not going
to wait for five minutes for that but
when it comes down to zero we are going
to die and restart the game and all of
that stuff if something is not clear
when it comes to this lecture make sure
that you ask in the comments down below
i don't know what this was
and
yeah i will see you guys in the next
video what up game dev shooters so now
we are going to create the health ui for
the enemy because we have one for the
player why shouldn't we have one for the
enemy so i'm going to right click user
interface and widget blueprint and this
one is going to be bp
enemy underscore health there you go you
can add ui if you want to i'm not going
to add i'm going to add here a progress
bar and i'm going to set his anchor at
the center so i'm also going to set the
position of this progress bar so for the
x position it is going to be minus 650
and the y actually minus not plus it set
it on the plus or minus 650
and over here the position y is going to
be minus 100 or actually 72 so minus 72.
over here the size is going to be
1 2
let's say one two
two two there you go or one two two zero
to one thousand two hundred and twenty
there you go over here 136 for the size
y i am also going to change here the
color to the red color so something like
this
and let's go over here fill out this
fill out the
the progress bar i'm also going to
rename the progress bar to i don't know
health progress bar something like that
and you need to make sure that this
check box over here it's checked so is
variable that's neat this right here
needs to be checked so make sure by
default it is for the progress bar but
if it's not for whatever reason make
sure that you check it
so now we can go inside of the enemy
blueprint and we can go here under add
component and we can filter for the
widget and yes we can also attach these
widgets as components
on our actors so this one is going to be
the enemy health so enemy health there
you go and compile and save and if i go
here we don't see it i mean we do it's
here but it's empty but if i go here in
the user interface and widget class and
if i click here to select the widget
class and i select the enemy one there
you go it's right there
so what do we need to do in order well
to make this work we need to resize it
first of course so size or the position
z is going to be 134
the size x is going to be 0.4 actually
the scale x 0.4 scale y 0.5 and scale z
point 16. so this is going to be the
health progress bar for the enemy
now
we need to get a reference to this so
that we can use it and display the
health value of the enemy when the enemy
you know
is dealt with damage so we can get here
now you would think that you can do
something like this get the enemy health
from here and from here get the progress
bar or health progress bar let me just
try to find it health
progress bar you cannot find it even
though over here if you go in the bp
enemy health you see that we have the
health progress bar so what's the issue
well the issue is that we first need to
cast this so we need to say over here
this enemy health goes here
and from it we need to get the user
widget
so here it is we need to get the user
widget and we need to cast to
bp enemy health
so now the widget and this user widget
is basically the widget this one right
here the widget class so that's the user
widget and we're casting that to enemy
health and when the cast succeeds we are
going to promote it into a variable
which is this one right here
and we can rename this variable so not
as bp enemy held but instead i'm going
to say enemy health ui ref so reference
to the enemy ui
and then from here i am going to get
that reference and from there i can get
the held progress bar and there you go
so now we have the health progress bar
and we can set the percentage so set
percent
and this goes so tick goes here and
we're going to check that every single
frame to set the percent if we lose any
health and we are going to right click
over here and get health and if you
remember inside of our class if i go
here we see that we have our health as a
u property that is blueprint read which
means the blueprints can read this value
and that is the reason why i can get it
over here but we know that the
percentage here goes from 0.0 up to 1.0
so we need to divide this by float and
that float value is going to be 100 and
then we're going to plug this in so now
we can simply compile and save this and
again because the percentage goes from
0.0 up to 1.0 we need to divide this
value by 100 this is in case if the
health value goes maximally up to 100
because now if the health is 100 and we
divide that by 100 we're going to set
the value here for the percent to one if
it's 90 90 divided by 100 is 0.9 and you
get the point
so now i can go over here and i can save
everything hit the play button and we
are going to see now that we have the
enemy the enemy has the health bar and
there you go you see when we you know
shoot the enemy look at that the health
bar is you know displaying and there you
go and we you know kill the enemy
there you go this is it's this simple to
create a health bar in unreal engine now
for if you don't see the health bar
being like this we don't see it for a
reason i'm not going to cover that i
covered it i believe in one of the
previous
mini courses but that is your assignment
find a way to make sure that this health
bar is always rotated towards the player
so that we can see it
that is the way how you can see this so
make sure it is rotated towards the
player and that can be easily done by
getting the player rotation calculating
you know the direction all of that stuff
google it it will be your practice if
something else is not clear in this
video make sure that you ask and i will
see you guys in the next one the before
last step is to create a door that is
going to serve as you know the winning
door so over here i'm going to right
click and create a new c sharp script
that
c sharp c plus plus what am i talking
about inherits from the actor and over
here we're going to call it door very
creative i'm the most creative person in
the world
nobody can top my creativity and i'm
just talking like this because we see
that it takes a little bit of time for
unreal engine to do its thing
so i'm going to sing and said
you owe me 50 bucks for this one it's
not five anymore i'm not i'm not singing
cheaply anymore so i want 50. my paypal
is in the link down below send me 50
bucks for this song
hopefully this is going to work
eventually so i'm going to probably
pause the video over here and wait until
this compiled thank you finally
so let's go in the you know see
in the visual studio and here it is we
have our door so what's going to happen
over here below our tick is that we are
going to create a few variables
so one is going to be a u property edit
anywhere and this is going to be our
class u static mesh component
component and it's a pointer and it's
capital s
there you go it's a pointer i'm going to
call it door mesh that you know this is
going to represent the door
also you property this one is going to
be added anywhere and over here class u
box component component and this one is
going to be the collision component or
basically
we are when we touch this box then we
are going to you know detect collision
with the player and there you go
and over here we have our on hit you can
just copy and paste this from the player
from the projectiles over here just go
and copy and paste this it's the same
function
basically we do this over and over again
because that's the only way how we can
detect collision between objects or
actors so there you go so just copy it
and over here the first thing that we
are going to do at the top of the door
is import or include all components so
make sure that you include all of these
components
and then we can continue pause the video
include these and now inside of here so
inside of the constructor
we are going to create the door mesh so
that's going to be equal to create
default sub object of you static mesh
component
and we are going to give it a name over
here with the text so the text is going
to say
mesh or you know whatever you want to
call it
our root component is going to be the
door mesh
we are also going to set the collision
component or create it so create default
sub object actually it's this right here
so create and the sub object is going to
be you box component
and text over here give it a name so the
name is going to be collision
component so component there you go but
just with a space over here so why not
and over here i need to add it inside of
a parenthesis
next i'm going to attach this collision
component so i'm going to say collision
component set up attachment and i'm
going to attach it on the door mesh
there you go
and there is one other thing that we
need to do but it's going to be here in
begin play we are going to take the
collision component and on component
begin overlap dot add dynamic
not internal dynamic dynamic like this
inside
so this and from there oh actually i did
not create this so i need to go here
right click and create the declaration
as we just saw
and take it from here
and add the and sign and there you go
so this is basically everything we need
to do
inside of our on hit we're simply going
to test if we collide with the player so
we're going to test a monster character
shooter or shooter character this is
going to be the char we are going to say
if that is equal to casting into the a
monster character shooter or monster
shooter character casting the other
actor
if this succeeds and we have the
char
char if we have the
well char character so if this succeeds
we have the character what we are going
to do is we are going to get the game
mode so we're going to say a
monster shooter game mode which you know
is a pointer and i'm going to call it my
game mode and i'm going to cast the so
i'm going to say cast into a monster
shooter
game mode and i'm casting
getting from the game play so gameplay
statics
get
game
mode passing here get the world as the
parameter and i need to close the
parentheses one more time this is not
the first time we did this so we are
getting the game mode from the gameplay
statics and if we have the game mode if
my
game mode so the cast was successful
this worked we're simply going to say my
game mode and from here restart
game or actually restart game play
passing through because we won
so when we win we are going to pass
through over here we talked about this
we saw this in action ctrl shift b so
that we can make sure that we don't have
any oopsies but these are basic things
so we're just detecting collision with
the player if you know we collide with
the player then we are going to simply
restart the game nothing complicated for
this game of course you can add more
things if you want to but that would be
it i have plenty other tutorials where
you can see
i don't know whatever you want to add
more components
more logic or whatever so over here i'm
going to create a new blueprint class
that's going to inherit from the door
and i'm going to call it bp door
i know creative i cannot be more
creative than this i i really can't
so for the door mesh over here just
filter for the door and there you go sm
door this is the one that we want
and for the door
it's going to stay as is but i'm going
to take the collision component from the
door
and the collision component i'm going to
set the x at minus 18 y is minus 48 z
102.
and from there i'm also going to set
here the box extent x to 15.
the y is going to be 45
and the z is going to be 100
and that's basically it so compile and
save
and we can just take the door now place
it here and this is where we need to
touch so when we touch here
we should restart the game and let's
test that out so when i get here
there you go i've restarted the game and
everything works again there you go i'm
traveling through time shooting this bad
boy and there you go look at that
so yeah and you see that the timer
restarts every single time look at that
so now it's at 300 again
and that would be it of course you can
and i have mini courses for that
publish before this one so you can look
that up
and
you can add some you know sign you won
congratulations blah blah blah stuff
like that do you want to play again
again add buttons yes no and so on and
so forth you get the point if something
was not clear what we did in this video
make sure that you ask and the last step
is to create the level and put this put
this door at the last you know part of
the level where we need to get after
passing all through all of the enemies
and stuff like that in order to win so i
will see you in the next video when we
create that now when it comes to the
level design for this particular game
what you can do is take the simple box
brush and then position them to form a
level i don't want to stall and gain
time on this mini course and this course
is five hours or whatnot and creating
the level is you know last 20 30 minutes
because these are all basic things what
i did is over here in the geometry i
just took this box and then simply you
know resized it so if i go over here
first delete this box if i go here into
the level
folder and area one if i take the first
floor and i simply deactivated see it's
simple box brush that's resized that's
all there is to it this is the first
wall that's also a box brush that's
resized and it will take a lot of time
for you to watch me create all of this
and basically what i would do is only
change here the locations location here
location here change the scale or
actually change here the brush settings
for x y and z that's everything
literally everything what i would do and
of course attach a material as you can
see we have this material and that's all
there is to it so you can see we have a
hall that we can pass and over here
another hall that we can pass and over
here you can see the third hole and
there you go this is the door where we
win the game when we pass the door of
course
on this whole level you are going to
create these enemies i only have one as
an example but of course you can
duplicate it just hold you know control
and then you know duplicate it there is
another enemy position this enemy here
then position another enemy here maybe
you can spice things up by adding here
so you can search for a cube maybe add a
few cubes here in your level resize them
of course jus
use them as shields to hide from the
enemies that can be your assignment or
you can download this complete project
link will be down below in the
description depending on you know where
you're watching this on youtube it's you
know in description of video on my
website it's right below the first video
i believe so you can download this
complete project where you can exactly
see the whole position of these box
brushes and you can copy this but i
highly encourage you to create a level
on your own and if you're on my website
watching this make sure that you post
down below to see for us to see
me and the people who are in the course
so that we can see the level that you
have created because i you know it's not
the point of this course is not just for
you to copy paste what i'm doing the
point is for you to learn
so yeah you can do that and i highly
encourage that and i didn't want to
waste your time by you watching me you
know just positioning all of these
because you will not learn anything
basically there is nothing to learn by
you know watching me positioning these
cubes left and right and resizing them
and so on and so forth there is nothing
to learn
there
so that would be it thank you for
watching this tutorial series and i
hope that you enjoyed because i enjoy
creating these and i will see you in the
next tutorial series take care